Heute geht es um Ausbeutung. Die Guaraní
sind ein indigenes Volk und leben in
Paraguay und Brasilien. Sie nutzen schon
seit Jahrhunderten Stevia zum Süßen von Tee,
bei Zeremonien und als Heilpflanze.
Mmmhhh. Und was enthält auch Stevia? Genau,
die mittlerweile aussortierte Coca Cola Life.
Zufälligerweise wächst heute kaum noch wildes
Stevia in Paraguay. Aber dafür wird es weltweit
verkauft, und zwar ohne dass die Guaraní etwas
davon abbekommen. Wie Unternehmen es
schaffen, Pflanzen zu klauen und aus
Biodiversität Profit zu schlagen, genau
darum geht es heute bei Doktor Whatson.
Wenn Großkonzerne von Wissen über
Heilpflanzen oder Lebensmitteln profitieren,
ohne die Betroffenen mit einzubeziehen, nennt
man das “Biopiraterie”. “Bio” hat nichts mit
ökologischen Landbau zu tun, sondern sagt
einfach, dass es hier um Lebewesen geht.
Bei Stevia sieht das so aus: Japanische Forscher
haben in Exkursionen um 1970 Steviasamen nach
Japan gebracht, aber auch eine halbe Million
Pflanzen, fast den gesamten Wildbestand. Daraus
wird ein Süßstoff extrahiert, der seit den
70er-Jahren dort kommerziell genutzt wird.
Aus *heutiger Sicht* ist das schon der
erste Biopiraterie-Fall in der Geschichte
von Stevia. Aber es geht noch weiter:
Bei der Zulassung in Europa hakt es
nämlich. CocaCola treibt gemeinsam mit dem
Megakonzern Cargill das Zulassungsverfahren
voran und entwickelt einen eigenen
Stevia-Süßstoff. Übrigens nur *eines*
der vielen Stevia-Patente von CocaCola.
2011 folgt die Zulassung – allerdings nicht
für die Stevia-Pflanze selbst, sondern für die
Steviolglykoside, die süßenden Stoffe. Obwohl
die aufwändig extrahiert werden müssen, wird der
Süßstoff als besonders “natürlich” vermarktet,
zum Beispiel in der Cola Life, der Stevia-Sprite
oder in der Pepsi Next. Das hat auch besonders
gut funktioniert, denn all diese Produkte gibt
es nicht mehr. Bei der Extraktion kann nämlich
ein unangenehmer Beigeschmack entstehen, der nicht
so gut ankam. Deshalb entwickelt die Firma Evolva,
die auch mit Cargill zusammenarbeitet, ein
Fermentationsverfahren: Genmanipulierte Hefen
produzieren Steviolglykoside ohne Beigeschmack
– dafür mit umso mehr Geschmäckle: Firmen,
die unabhängig vom Stevia-Anbau sind, und Guaraní,
die immer noch keinen Cent von den Profiten sehen.
Auch das wird als Biopiraterie kritisiert.
Und dafür gibt es noch viele weitere Beispiele:
Rooibos-Tee, Reis oder die Kapland-Pelargonie in
[Finger] “natürlichen” Erkältungsmedikamenten. Oft
geht Biopiraterie einher mit einem Biopatent.
Aber – und das ist vielleicht die wichtigste
Frage dieses Videos hier: können Lebewesen,
kann genetisches Material, eine Erfindung
sein? Sollte man Leben patentieren können?
Darauf gibt es keine eindeutige Antwort.
Grundsätzlich dürfen auch biologisches Material
und die Verfahren, mit denen es hergestellt wird,
patentiert werden. In der EU dürfen
aber “im Wesentlichen biologische”,
also konventionelle und gentechnik-freie Verfahren
[hier am besten an den Fingern zählen o. ä. um den
Satz zu gliedern. 1: Verfahren. 2: Pflanzensorten.
3: Tierrassen] und Pflanzensorten – und übrigens
auch Tierrassen – nicht patentiert werden.
Manche Firmen versuchen aber, das zu umgehen,
indem bestimmte Eigenschaften, Verfahren oder
Verwendungsmöglichkeiten unter Patentschutz
gestellt werden. Der Saatgutkonzern DuPont hat
im Jahr 2000 zum Beispiel Maispflanzen mit einer
bestimmten Konzentration an Öl und Ölsäure
patentieren lassen – also eine Eigenschaft,
keine bestimmte Sorte. Unter das Patent fallen
also die speziellen, von DuPont gezüchteten,
Pflanzen, aber eben auch andere natürliche
Sorten mit hohem Ölgehalt und sogar nicht
einmal existente oder noch nicht entdeckte
Sorten. Hätte niemand Einspruch eingelegt,
hätten Bauern in Peru oder Mexiko Lizenzgebühren
zahlen müssen – für den Anbau von Mais,
den sie schon Ewigkeiten genutzt haben.
Durch Biopiraterie verlieren Kleinbauern
und lokale Gemeinschaften also
die Kontrolle über Ressourcen,
die sie teils seit Jahrhunderten nutzen. Die
liegen plötzlich in der Hand von Großkonzernen.
Ok. Wo waren wir stehengeblieben?
Ach ja, Biopiraterie. Wie lässt
sich *die* denn jetzt verhindern?
Dafür tritt 2014 das Nagoya-Protokoll
in Kraft, in dem das sogenannte Access and Benefit
Sharing geregelt wird. Das bedeutet: Der Zugang zu
Ressourcen wird geteilt, aber eben auch der Nutzen
– zum Beispiel in Form von Geld, Technologie oder
gemeinsamen Rechten an den Entwicklungen.
Klingt super, aber es gibt da noch einige
Schwierigkeiten. Jedes Land kann selbst festlegen,
*welche* Ressourcen *wie* geschützt werden. Aber
es kann sehr schwierig sein, herauszufinden, wo
der Ursprung von Ressourcen oder Wissen ist. Wer
genau gehört zu einer “Community”,
einem indigenen Volk oder Stamm?
Geistige Eigentumsrechte bestehen nur für eine
gewisse Zeit. Verliert auch das traditionelle
Wissen irgendwann diese Exklusivität?
Auf das alles gibt es keine Antwort,
sagen auch die Expertinnen vom Nagoya Protocol
HuB, mit denen wir für dieses Video gesprochen
haben. Es geht hier also weniger um ein
knallhartes “Meins oder Deins”, sondern eher um
Moral und Fairness. Im Fall der Kapland-Pelargonie
wurde zum Beispiel ein Teil der Patente fallen
gelassen und ein Benefit-Sharing-Abkommen mit den
Xhosa geschlossen, was aber zwei andere Gruppen
außen vor ließ. Also, alles nicht so einfach.
Noch schwieriger wird es durch technische
Entwicklungen. Mittlerweile ist es möglich,
digitale Sequenzinformationen über die DNA
auszutauschen, ohne das genetische Material
jemals *physisch* untersucht zu haben.
Viele Forscher stellen die Gensequenzen ihres
Forschungsgegenstands online zur Verfügung. Andere
Wissenschaftler können dann darauf zugreifen.
Coole Sache, aber das kann auch zum Problem fürs
ABS werden: Ein deutsches Institut untersucht
– mit ABS-Abkommen – Ebola-Virusvarianten;
anhand der Probe einer 28-Jährigen aus Guinea.
Die DSI wird online veröffentlicht. Ein
US-amerikanisches Pharma-Unternehmen nutzt die DSI
und produziert ein Medikament gegen Ebola. Dafür
gab’s Millionen an finanzieller Unterstützung
der Regierung. Aber: Jetzt hat halt einfach
ein Unternehmen in der Hand, ob und für wie viel
Geld Ebola-Medikamente in *die Länder* gelangen,
in denen sie gebraucht werden.
[Eigene Meinung]
Ok, fassen wir das alles mal zusammen: Unternehmen
entwickeln Nahrungsmittel oder Medikamente und
verwenden dabei Wissen von Gemeinschaften, das
dort zum Teil seit Jahrhunderten genutzt wird.
Erstmal noch kein Problem, wenn ihr mich fragt.
Aus altem Wissen zu lernen, ist keine Straftat
und kann uns wirklich weiterhelfen. Solange man
eine Balance findet, bei der die Benefits fair
geteilt werden und niemand auf der Strecke bleibt.
Aber trotz des Nagoya-Protokolls, was genau das
regeln soll, gibt es noch viele offene Fragen.
Zum Beispiel, was die digitale Weitergabe von
Gensequenzen angeht: Eine super Methode,
um Informationen zu teilen und im Fall von
neuen Krankheitserregern schnell reagieren zu
können. Dort bleibt vielleicht nicht immer Zeit,
um ein herkömmliches ABS auszuhandeln.
Aber gleichzeitig kann es so passieren,
dass ein globales Machtungleichgewicht an
Wissen, Medizin und Geld verstärkt wird.
Wie man damit am besten umgeht, wissen wir nicht.
Natürlich muss weiter an biologischen Ressourcen
geforscht werden, weil sie unverzichtbar
für den Fortschritt der Menschheit sind.
Bis wir aber tatsächlich bei einem gerechten
Access and Benefit Sharing angekommen sind,
das das traditionelle Wissen schützt und
schätzt und den Gruppen gleichzeitig nicht
ihre Lebensgrundlage entzieht, dauert es wohl
noch. Bis dahin, bleibt neugierig. Euer Cedric.